berkeley telling us about this so thank
you for having me and I apologize before
being between lunch but I will try to
make this mildly quick so I'm going to
talk about my thesis work and the cease
work sort of focused on trying to answer
the following question how are we going
to take the advances we've developed in
parallel hardware and apply them to sort
of the massive structured machine
learning problems that we'd like to be
able to solve and so during my thesis as
a PhD student I was enabled to
re-envision the entire stack to sort of
think not only about the algorithms but
the systems to support them as well so
we developed a new stack to address
these problems and sort out the top
level of stack we use graphical models
as a standard representation of the sort
of structured problems we'd like to
solve machine learning and then below
that we developed new parallel
algorithms for distributed inference on
these models and then to support those
algorithms we were able to develop a new
system called GraphLab which is a graph
parallel system for doing computation of
the algorithms that we described here so
today I want to talk about the
algorithms there are sort of underlying
structure and how that motivated the
design of a sort of new system to
approach graph computation that's
slightly different than what's been
talked about today all right so
graphical models are kind of a useful
primitive for us to build these
algorithms on top of because they sort
of provide a standard representation for
each of our problems so ranging from
like problems from protein structure
prediction computer vision to machine
translation all of these problems have a
graphical representation so I can sort
of divorce myself from focusing on the
problem specific nature and encode that
in a graph and then to design sort of
generic algorithms that I can apply to
those graphs to do inference and so
today I'm going to talk about two
vignettes to particular algorithms that
we studied and sort of the properties of
those algorithms that motivate the
design of the system okay so I'm going
to look at belief propagation or loopy
belief propagation and gibbs sampling
okay all right so loopy belief
propagation is a pretty common algorithm
for graphical model inference and it's
an iterative algorithm in which for each
variable I'm going to try to estimate
sort of marginal beliefs about the
distribution of the posterior
distribution for this variable
and so if I take the center variable
here the reddish color circle around it
I begin by reading messages so the
belief propagation algorithm is an
iterative algorithm which I read
messages from my neighboring vertices I
use those messages to estimate my new
belief so my new marginal and then using
that new marginal I'm going to compute
new messages to my neighboring vertices
they'll receive those messages update
their beliefs in the process repeat okay
now this seems like an embarrassingly
parallel algorithm in fact many have
studied this problem and said look we
can make a very parallel version this
algorithm by assigning processors to our
vertices so if I assign a processor or
virtual processor to each of my vertices
then I can execute this algorithm
entirely in parallel right so each
vertex is going to begin by receiving
the messages from the neighboring
vertices computing a new belief and then
based on those beliefs sending new
messages to neighboring vertices this is
an iterative process and its proposed by
many people okay so that's a parallel
algorithm we might stop there and say
look we've got a very parallel way to
solve this inference problem but we
started think about is this an efficient
way to solve this problem so I have lots
of course but I want to also be
relatively efficient in my approach to
solving a parallel problem so we could
ask the question is synchronous loopy
belief propagation and efficient
parallel algorithm so the way we sort of
approach this problem is we want to step
back and say what is the structure the
sequential structure of inference in
these models so you have a big loopy
graph for a medium-sized loopy graph and
I'd like to sort of reason about the
underlying sequential problem I can cast
that as sort of a sequence of strongly
connected variables it might be embedded
in my underlying model right and I want
to reason about how does the algorithm I
just described the very power girdim
perform on this sequence of variables
will call us a chain graphical model and
so if i take this chain and just focus
on these variables i can think about
what happens when i try to run inference
on just this subproblem right so what i
can do is let's suppose i introduce
evidence i make some observations about
the variables at either end of the chain
maybe the variable one end is very
likely greeting the variable the other
end is red you can tell them apart great
okay so now i'm going to run this
synchronous algorithm bulk synchronous
parallel algorithm to compute all of
these messages in parallel
right so at once i'm going to compute i
have n variables in my chain i'm going
to compute to end message calculations
but i have P processors i have p
physical processors so the running time
of that one iteration is just 2 n over P
because you might have noticed evidence
only moved one step right so the green
evidence moved one variable from the
left and the red evidence are sorry from
the right and the red evidence moved one
variable to the right okay so if I
repeat this another iteration my
evidence moves one variable at a time
and so it will take n iterations of this
process for the evidence to move across
the graph okay so the running time of
this final algorithm is 2n squared over
P right so for n iterations and each
running time to n over P so we might
stop there and say well that's a very
parallel algorithm it has almost will
has perfect scaling but how does this
perform compared to the best serial
algorithm that construct for this simple
model right so we can go back and say
the natural and the obvious algorithm
for solving this problem see early on
one processor this is used a forward
backward algorithm in which we pass
messages forward and then backward and
this has running time to n so unless
we're willing to buy n processors we're
actually better off just running for
this chain the serial algorithm it's
more efficient right now we could go
right now that we focus on this chain
what's the best algorithm we could
propose for inference in this message
passing pattern and so the best
algorithm we can use for loopy belief
propagation on this chain is to run
messages in in parallel in the forward
and backwards directions so that gives
us a running time for inference and just
this little chain of n so we can be
optimal using just two processors and
getting running time of n now unless we
introduce additional approximations
we're sort of constrained at this point
for message passing belief propagation
style algorithms but reality a lot of
the models we have have sort of
contracted potentials or they have we
introduce sort of numerical
approximation in our execution right and
so the way we can think about that as we
return to our chain we think about the
sequences of messages passed along this
chain is a sequence of distributions we
could try to reason about what happens
if we just cut the chain so we cut the
chain from 3 to 4 and instead inject
this uniform message and we
past this uniform message along the
chain what happens so for a lot of
models you have this contractive
structure where even though we've
injected a noisy message into for that
message ends up looking at the end like
the message having passed along the
entire chain so this sort of shorter
distance in which we get an epsilon
level approximation we call the Talib
salon distance alright so this is a
theoretical construct that lets his
reason about the parameters effect on
the underlying structure okay and this
is going to include the sort of minimal
sequential sub problem we need to reason
about for these chains now with that
idea in mind we can now propose an
algorithm that's going to be efficient
for this chain that's going to exploit
this tau epsilon structure the algorithm
is actually very simple we just divide
the chain evenly across our processors
and then within each of these processor
blocks we run the forward backward
algorithm from the interior from the
exterior of the block to the root and
then from the route back to the exterior
right then we exchanged messages across
processors and then again repeat this
process okay and now we were able to
show that this particular algorithm on
this chain model has running time n over
P plus tau epsilon right so I have n
variables P processors until epsilon
becomes my sequential component so this
nicely breaks the prom into a parallel
component in rupee and 2 epsilon
sequential component now if we restrict
our attention of these chains we can
actually show that this is also the
optimal algorithm for this type of model
okay so now we've just sort of described
a motif that really focuses on chains be
really in the first place one to solve
inference in much larger loopy models
and the way we can do that is take this
sort of pattern and generalize it and
the way we did that is we introduced a
splash operation so this is a
fundamental building block on which you
could build other parallel algorithms on
the graphs as the way this works as
before in the chain we innominate some
vertex to VR center and then we're going
to build a breadth-first search spanning
tree around that vertex I now having
constructed that tree we're going to
move messages along the tree from the
root or from the leaves to the root and
then back from the root to the leaves
right so using this pattern on this tree
we're able to more efficiently solve the
inference problem on this tree
substructure and so we're going to take
this sort of chain
full technique applied to loopy graphs
and then be able to generalize it as a
distributed primitive so we take our
large graph we can take this little
kernel this breadth first search
spanning tree we split our graph across
processors then run these little splash
operations on each machine just as
before communicating messages across the
partition right so this is a primitive
for building graph algorithms or
graphical model inference algorithms on
these distrito graphs and one of the
things we found in our work and doing
these imprints algorithms is the need
for prioritization so I didn't mention
this little bit earlier in many cases we
have some notion of which vertices
should be computed first to achieve an
efficient execution and so in our work
we also looked at introducing priority
queues on each machine to manage the
prioritization of vertex computation and
so if we introduce a priority to
priority queue on CP 1 here the idea is
that we're going to take the vertex
which if we compute on next so have the
most impact and tour towards convergence
to take the highest priority vertex
execute the splash operation at that
vertex and that splash operation will
reprioritize our vertices so is
essentially something like residual
belief propagation for this familiar
thing so reprioritize our vertices and
then execute again now I'd also mention
this bit of a challenge if we want to
distribute this and so one thing we're
doing here is we're essentially
assigning priority queues at the
processor level and not across the
entire distribute environment but even
at the processor level we actually get a
pretty big game so let me illustrate how
this actually performs putting all these
pieces together on a real model or a
real synthetic model so here's a picture
of a noisy sunset I have a picture of a
sunset and i've added noise to it and i
can induce a grid markov random feel on
this side set and this is going to
encode my smoothness prior between
pixels right and now what I'm going to
try to do is run loopy belief
propagation to infer the posterior
distribution or posterior color of each
pixel in this image and the way you can
think about the or the challenge of this
problem is actually determining the
pixels along the boundary of the sunset
so if you look at the bottom of the
image it's very easy to infer from your
neighborhood that you're likely in the
black region but as you get close to
these boundaries it becomes much harder
now if I use this splash primitive on a
grid it doesn't actually look like
circles splash burns on grids look like
diamonds so initially what we'll see is
it when the algorithm runs it's going to
uniformly spread these diamonds over the
entire picture and then ideally through
prioritisation it'll focus is
computation on the challenging regions
so on the right I'm going to show a
video where bright pixels correspond to
things being updated more often and dark
pixels things less so initially we see a
uniform covering so this is executing in
parallel but as you are going to proceed
it's going to start to identify the
regions of highest residual and focus
computation there and so as we get to
the end we've seen that the amount of
time spent over all on computation was
predominantly focused on the challenging
regions of the image okay so the
algorithm is able to identify and focus
on the hidden sequential structure so
one of the key things we've seen so far
here actually let's look some quick
results so some representative results
of the system we can apply this to
real-world problems so protein
interaction models and if we look at
just on a multi-core system as a
function of processors the
embarrassingly parallel bulk synchronous
model the blue line and the red line the
splash primitive even at one processor
the splash algorithm is faster than the
bulk synchronous system and we can also
look at the speed up so we look at the
scaling relative to the fastest serial
algorithm we actually see that the
splash out rim being the fastest serial
algorithm is still able to scale
relatively well and this is partly due
some improvements in cache efficiency by
using these tree primitives and then
finally if we look at work and this is
something is very important when
designing large scale systems is to
think about the total work being done in
your computation so as we increase
number of processors we don't add more
work and in general the splash primitive
it allows you to substantially reduce
the amount of work required to achieve
an accurate answer addition there's some
neat side effects that we get faster
faster more efficient virgins converted
is more often and we're able to achieve
better prediction accuracy all right so
now if I step back one of the ideas it
sort of became central here is to
exploit asynchrony and prioritization to
build a more efficient computation and
so now we can sort of look at how that
also affects another inference tasks
give template so we looked at belief
propagation now we can think about Gibbs
sampling all right so Gibbs sampling was
introduced in 1984 and it's one of the
workhorses of modern Batian statistics
the idea of Gibbs sampling is I'm going
to associate random very
again with the vertex of my graph and
I'm going to flip these variables at
random to estimate a posterior
distribution so we can think of each of
these variables as corresponding to a
sample of coins maybe and then I'm going
to sequentially pick a variable for my
model let's say the center vertex and
then I'm going to build the conditional
that vertex based on its neighborhood so
we look at the neighboring vertices
constructed conditional and I'm going to
flip that coin with respect to that
conditional and that will generate the
next sample in my sequence so this is a
serial algorithm for sampling and it's
pretty powerful invasion statistics and
so we'd like to paralyze this all right
so one way you could approach this
promise to construct a synchronous gibbs
sampler this would be the bulk
synchronous approach right so I take all
of my variables and I try to assign a
processor to each one of them and then I
try to flip them all at once right so
it's embarrassingly parallel process so
it's embarrassing peril but it also
converges to the wrong distribution so
it's fast but wrong let me illustrate
why it's wrong so it's actually a very
simple illustration suppose I just have
two variables and my model says that
they're strongly correlated and I'm
going to start out with them having
different assignments so start my Markov
chain with the top variable white the
bottom variable black so what happens
when I execute this algorithm serially
so top chain here I'm going to flip the
top variable and with high probability
it's going to try to match the bottom
variable right now I repeat this process
every time I flip a variable it's going
to try to match the other variable right
and what I'm going to produce in the end
is a sequence of variables which share
the same color so I'll have long
sequences of similar colored variables
now if I run this in parallel each
variable is going to wake up and try to
flip itself and match the others
assignment and so i get is this
oscillating pattern reach variable flips
to try to match the other right now if i
look at these two Chainz the top chain
encodes the strong positive correlation
that i had in my model so it's
preserving the model distribution but
the bottom chain has actually the very
opposite strong negative correlation so
it's showing the opposite of what my
models trying to encode so it's a very
simple example of just two variables and
this prom actually can grow to larger
models so essentially adjacent variables
cannot be sampled simultaneously
of course this is a pretty well-known
result so in our work we develop sort of
three techniques built around this
asynchronous locking asynchronous
primitives to construct convergent
versions of this gibbs sampler that also
scale the first idea is very simple we
use classic ideas from graph coloring to
construct a serializable parallel
execution the second technique we
introduce a locking strategy that allows
us to essentially lock our mark off
blanket and allow asynchronous
computation of a gift simpler and the
third result is going to take that
splash primitive and essentially build
something very similar for Gibbs
sampling so let me quickly go through
the chromatic sampler so the chromatic
sampler I take my graphical model as I
had here I construct a que coloring of
the graphical model so I in this case
it's a two colorable model and then I
can sample all the variables in the same
color in parallel right so I can use for
any Markov random field I construct the
coloring sample all the variables in the
same color in parallel now what's kind
of neat about this is actually can show
that this corresponds to a linearization
their serial equivalents that I can take
variables of the same color and place
them on chain and this is equivalent to
having executed my cereal gibbs sampler
in this pattern that's very powerful
lets me reason about the parallel
execution ok and that also allows me to
describe the flying theorem which is
kind of neat so we can prove that this
sampler converges the correct
distribution we can more importantly
quantify the acceleration of mixing so
here we can say that we get an n over P
for n variables P processors speed up
with AK dependent so my graph coloring
essentially describes a serial component
of this problem okay and this actually
holds for any graphical model not just
chains this is a general result okay so
that gives me one technique to construct
a parallel gibbs sampler but we can do
better and so by introducing a locking
protocol I can essentially say that
vertices adjacent to each other can't
run simultaneously so I can allow the
system to enforce this serialize ability
constraint and doing that I'm able to
now construct an asynchronous version of
the splash procedure for Gibbs sampling
so I'm going to illustrate the algorithm
here so I begin with my big grid model
and i'm going to pick a variable from
the model at random and i'm going to
grow a spanning tree actually i'm going
to grow a very special kind of spanning
tree this is called a VA cyclic spanning
tree or in a general we're going to grow
it's a thin junction tree so a
collection of variables that are
connected then I'm going to then be able
to sample jointly I can do this in
parallel so I can build many trees at
once because it's locking protocol so
the system again is going to enforce the
serializable ax t constraints all right
so they're separated by a markov blanket
and i'm going to focus just on the left
tree so if I just soak some that the
single tree here I can actually use this
tree that I've constructed to draw a
joint sample for all the variables in
that tree anyway I do that as I'm going
to apply this the belief propagation
algorithm which is now exact for this
tree to calibrate it so our past
messages from the boundary to the
interior and then having calibrated the
tree I can do backwards sampling right
so I'm going to do an asynchronous
backward sampling what I simple one
variable and as I go down the tree I get
increasingly more parallelism in my
sampling strategy in addition I'm
allowing myself to build new trees
asynchronously as this process proceeds
so we had that primitive again taking
that splash idea and bring it to give
sampling I can now actually use that to
build a prioritized version of a gift
sampler so here i have my noisy image on
the left i'm going to introduce a
measure of correlation and so if i do
not apply measure of correlation i get
these regular structures so these are
the breadth first search spanning trees
or actually breadth first search thin
junction trees on the right if i apply
at activity allowing my sampler could
actually grow to regions in the graph so
it's going to do a block update to
regions a strong correlation so i can
combine these ideas and i can now give
some very simple results so here i'll
apply this technique to Markov random
fields for for markov logic networks and
so we can compare just a spat the splash
sample i described in the chromatic
sampler and so when I have strong
correlation structure this additional
blocking can have a big impact of the
convergence Malzone so I could look at
likely as a function of time I can get
much higher likelihood samples I can
look at mixing across chains so I can
measure of the mixing mixing in my
samplers and finally I can look at speed
up so these techniques again by
exploiting this blocking structure you
have
our cache efficiency and get a pretty
good speed up okay all right so in
general we see this splash this flash
technique can outperform sort of
chromatic techniques of bulk synchronous
set up on strongly correlated models
okay so I've talked a lot about sort of
asynchronous parallel algorithms for
draft computation and now we might ask
how would I implement these algorithms
so when I started my thesis we basically
but wrote all these from scratch and MPI
and P threads and as a pain and as we
work through it we start to realize this
sort of a primitive that we can build on
top of so I'm going to try to describe
that primitive that we built these
algorithms on top of this is the system
we call graph lab and so this is
answering the question is how we design
and more importantly implement these
graph parallel algorithms for inference
and so we've heard a lot about Hadoop
Hadoop is sort of the go to system when
trying to build a large-scale parallel
computation at least in the machine
learning community and the idea that i'm
going to process all of my records in
parallel so the data parallel task and
then there's some final aggregation and
i might cheney's together to get an
iterative algorithm right the reality of
those graph product computation looks
different right so I have a graph where
you should my vertices are connected I'm
trying to reason about that and my
computation lives at the vertex level
and interacts with the neighbors right
so if i look at my computational
primitive i'm thinking at the vertex
level and how I have my state changes is
a function in my neighborhood and the
parallelism in all these stories emerges
from running multiple vertices
simultaneously but not all vertices
subsets okay and so there are two
systems that have sort of grown out of
this area at least in the cloud
computing world soap raggle which is
developed by google and GraphLab which
was developed as part of my thesis so
i'm going to talk about GraphLab today
so grass lab implements is essentially
the we call the graph parallel
abstraction in which the user the
machine learning researcher for example
defines a program that lives on every
single vertex in the graph so your
defines a user-defined vertex program
that runs on every single vertex okay so
we have billions of vertices we have the
same program running billions of times
essentially and these programs can
interact along edges in the graph so the
interaction of programs constrain to the
the adjacency struck for the draft and
systems like preggo these programs
interact by passing messages to
neighboring vertices where systems like
GraphLab these programs in iraq through
shared state and actually i think for
machine learning algorithms this is more
powerful because it essentially isolates
the user from having to reason about the
movement of data and instead they're
easy user thinks about the state of a
vertex like context of its neighbors or
its Markov blanket if we're designing
graphical model and Prince algorithms
now parallelism in this story again
emerges by running multiple vertices
simultaneously so the graph lab system
with the shared state also had this
concept of scheduling cool and so we
have this idea effectively of a shared
schedule though it's actually
distributed primitive and which each of
my CPUs are going to pull the next
vertex to process because remember we're
not pressing all the vertices at once
we're processing a subset so we take
let's say vertices a and B we execute
the vertex programs for those vertices
on a and B on the physical processors
and those little vertex programs can
then trigger future computation so this
is essentially scheduling the
neighboring vertex to receive the
message i just sent to them right and
that neighboring computation then goes
back into the scheduler right and we can
repeat this process again pulling stuff
from the scheduler and here we build a
breadth-first search traversal to graph
again scheduling these things back and
what's cool is a schedule allows us to
then introduce the concept of priority
right so I can change the way my
scheduling algorithm works and get very
different behaviors for each of my
overall algorithms the only thing that
graph up that it's does that's pretty
unique is it guarantees serializability
right so if I'm going to run vertex
programs on these three vertices I can
actually do so safely because I know
that they don't modify any state the
other vertex can read but if I try to
add a fourth vertex this model and try
to run this program at the same time
it's no it's now no longer consistent
now this graph hubs runtime the actual
system is going to detect these
conflicting edges and prevent this
execution from occurring so it's
automatically going to maintain
serializability so we built the system
and as we started to test it on
multi-core and then large-scale discrete
environments we ran into an interesting
problem and this is alluded to earlier
today and that is a challenge of power
log rafts I want to briefly mention what
this is and sort of how we approached it
right so parallel graphs are ubiquitous
the real world graphs we want to reason
about for real machine learning
computation
don't have the regular grid structure I
keep drawing in all my illustrations
instead they have a sort of starlight
motif where we have let's say a high
degree vertex to Center maybe it's it's
brock obama as many followers along the
boundary so they have a small set of
high degree vertices and a very large
set of low degree vertices and so with
GraphLab one of the things we had to do
is feel it figure out how to deal with
this vertex Q in a large-scale discrete
environment and one of the things that
we did is we actually exploit the
abstraction itself so we do as we say we
have these hiding vertices we're
actually going to transform the
underlying graph splitting these high
degree vertices and essentially bringing
their degree down and also splitting the
cross machine so developing new
partitioning techniques that exploit
this degree structure and then the more
important and challenging part is we're
going to be able to transform the
computation so the user is going to
program for the original graph we're
going to have it executes equivalently
and efficiently on this transformed
graph this is going to allow us to take
programs that are written to live at a
vertex and split that program itself
across the cluster and the way we do
that is actually pretty straightforward
we're going to exploit a common
structure in our algorithms whether
that's belief propagation PageRank
connect components Gibbs sampling all of
them have this this the standard pattern
where the program living each vertex
begins by computing some statistic of
its neighborhood whether or not seeing
the product of the messages or the sum
of the ranks of neighboring vertices so
this first operation is a commutative
associative operation we can exploit
that commutative associative structure
to transform the graph then after we've
received this message or the statistics
they are neighboring vertices we update
our vertex state and now this doesn't
depend on neighboring vertices and this
is entirely data parallel to vertex
level and finally when we compute these
name these messages to neighboring
vertices or trigger a neighboring
vertices for future computation that
operation itself is edge parallel so
again this is highly parallel operation
so taking these three steps we can
actually split a program apart across
the cluster so I'm not actually not
going to talk about the design of the
system to do that today I'm just going
to talk about some of the results so we
built that system it's actually called
GraphLab too but you can check it out at
graph Abed org it's designed to run in
the cloud environment so it runs on an
ec2 cloud it's runs on top of npip
threads and HDFS
on top but we've also built a wide range
of actual machine learning and data
mining applications to sort of validate
the system but also to use it to solve
real problems and so one of the first
things that everyone does when you build
a graph parallel system as you run
PageRank so we to wrap a drink on our
system although is designed for graphic
model inference and the idea here is
we're going to run page rank on your
graph with 40 million users and 1.4
billion links and so we can look at sort
of the published results of other
systems today and then we can look at in
the context of graph lab and just using
these high level primitives we're able
to achieve an order of magnitude
performance improvement over the current
systems for solving this problem and
this is again exploiting natural graph
structure another thing we could do is
maybe a little more important is trying
to reason about topical tributions of
documents right so we can apply Gibbs
sampling to the LDA model for the
Wikipedia dataset and so here we have a
data set with 2.6 million documents 8.3
million words and 500 million tokens
okay so this is a computationally
intensive algorithm and here's sort of
what we see so a system design a yahoo
for solving this problem of a very
optimized system can achieve actually
150 million tokens per second with a
thousand topics / token so this is a
pretty good result we built a system or
we built it we implemented this
algorithm on top of graph lab and so
using just 64 machines we're able to
achieve 110 million tokens per second
for a thousand topics but this is using
200 lines of code written in just four
human hours so this is allowing a high
level engineer or research scientist or
even a machine learning person to build
a scalable system and to do it in a
short amount of time another and I guess
the final task I want to talk about his
triangle accounting and so actually i
surly mentioned this a little bit
earlier so this is work that he'd worked
on to try to compute the number of
triangles in a graph so this is for
every vertex winnipeg compute number of
triangles that vertex a member okay so
we're going to run this in the Twitter
graph this is 40 million users at one
point four billion links so the
technique he describes actually pretty
good this is a technique running on
Hadoop and we're going to sort of
optimized to exploit the bulk
synchronous structure of Hadoop and so
here using 1500 machines you're able to
process this problem in 423 minutes so
that's 30 4.8 billion triangles
it's actually a pretty pretty big
triangle counting task okay 30 4.8
billion triangles so GraphLab with our
newest number on 64 machines can do this
in 15 seconds solving the same problem
counting all 30 4.8 billion triangles
and labeling the motifs so that's a
thousand times faster now in Syria's
defense this is actually Python code
written in Hadoop running on a provision
cluster an our code is C++ code running
on 64 dedicated machines but actually
when we go and compare this against some
of the state-of-the-art serial problems
or serial systems for solving this we're
getting almost perfect scaling so what
we've achieved here is we've exploited
the adjacency structure and in fact
reused our neighborhood information to
be able to efficiently compute this
several orders of magnitude faster than
some of the fastest reported results
okay so in summary this idea of the
graph lab and graph up to the systems we
built exploit the common patterns and
graph computation and they allow us to
essentially represent real world graphs
in new ways and to exploit that to
efficiently execute graph algorithms on
top of those achieving orders of
magnitude improvements in performance so
I'll stop there any questions
you